zdf heute live herzlich willkommen ein
bedeutsamer tag in der geschichte der
landwirtschaft sei das heute sagt
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
nachdem jahrzehntelang die gräben
zwischen landwirtinnen und landwirten
politik und verbraucherinnen und
verbrauchern immer tiefer wurden gibt es
jetzt einen konsens aber auch der begann
mit einem streit 2009 10 sind tausende
bauern in deutschland in ganz
deutschland auf die straße gegangen zu
sogenannten trecker protesten
sie fanden die auflagen für die
tierhaltung und beim düngen zum beispiel
als viel zu streng und aus diesen
protesten wurden dann gespräche
die bundesregierung berief eine
zukunftskommission ein verantwortlicher
ausland wirtschaft handel industrie und
umweltschutz haben über monate
miteinander verhandelt und sich gefragt
wie sieht die landwirtschaft der zukunft
aus und heute hat die kommission ihre
ergebnisse an bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel übergeben
eine die mit in der kommission saß und
einer der bei den protesten damals 2009
10 mit dabei war sind heute in der
sendung miriam rapior vorsitzende der
jugend im bund für umwelt und
naturschutz bnd und malte messerschmidt
landwirt aus niedersachsen auf instagram
unterwegs auch als bauern bengel und von
dort auch vielleicht einigen bekannt
frau rapior die erste frage geht an sie
ist das ein bedeutsamer tag in der
geschichte der landwirtschaft aus ihrer
sicht aus meiner sicht ich mein ich habe
die geschichte der landwirtschaft bin 24
noch nicht so lange begleitet aber
seitdem ich bei der b- und d-jugend bin
demonstriere ich für eine ökologisierung
der landwirtschaft und mit diesem
kompromiss uns ist uns der umwelt in der
landwirtschaft der schulterschluss
gelungen wir sind stehen zusammen stehen
für diesen kompromiss für diesen ersten
schritt der transformation der
landwirtschaft in eine ökologische
richtung das heißt ja es ist ein
bedeutsamer schritt hier beginnt jetzt
eine transformation die veränderung der
landwirtschaft so dass sie innerhalb
ihrer grenzen wirtschaftet
wie seht ihr zuhause das wie sehen die
userinnen und user das beteiligt euch
schreibt uns gerne eure meinungen auch
welche erwartungen oder welche ansprüche
ihr habt welche hoffnungen ihr habt und
welche sorgen auch und welche ideen
vielleicht was die zukunft der
landwirtschaft an geht über die sozialen
medien in die fragen und kommentare
bitte und ansonsten an diese e mail
adresse wenn er die zdf heute app nutzt
die e mail adresse
die eingeblendet ist herr messerschmidt
auch für sie ein historischer tag heute
auf jeden fall
es ist wirklich ein großer schritt der
da gemacht wurde und es ist toll dass
wirklich alle sich an einen tisch
gesetzt haben und das ist zu einem
konstruktiven ergebnis kam nach nur
einem jahr
das ist ja das gibt es nicht nicht nicht
ganz so oft und das ist tatsächlich so
dass man sich gar nicht dass man
eigentlich gar nicht glauben kann dass
das eine einigung ist die tatsächlich
auch nachhaltig ist und die nicht sofort
wieder auseinander fliegt wenn es dann
um konkrete beschlüsse geht deshalb
schauen wir uns erst mal an was denn
überhaupt die zukunftskommission
erarbeitet hat was drin steht julia
schröter fast das zusammen virtuell wird
der kanzlerin der zukunfts bericht
landwirtschaft übergeben
der kern ein weiter so kann es nicht
geben nachhaltigkeit soll zum
geschäftsmodell werden die wichtigsten
punkte im bericht die landwirtschaft
soll möglichst naturnah sein
der einsatz von pestiziden im sinne des
eu ziels bis 2030 möglichst um 50
prozent gesenkt werden
das tierwohl soll gestärkt werden etwa
durch größere ställe diesen umbau sieht
die kommission als
gesamtgesellschaftliche aufgabe die mit
öffentlichen geldern gestützt werden
soll
auch bei den eu subventionen soll sich
laut bericht etwas ändern
bis 2030 sollen direktzahlungen nach
fläche gestoppt werden stattdessen soll
es zahlungen konkret für ökologische
leistungen geben
die realität hängt dem deutlich
hinterher die eu agrarminister mit
landwirtschaftsministerin klöckner haben
gerade erst beschlossen bis 2027
lediglich 25 prozent der zahlungen
öko leistungen zu koppeln wenn ich hier
in die chats gucke dann sehe ich dass es
vor allem eine große
auseinandersetzungen gibt zum thema
fleisch ja oder nein zum thema
tierhaltung werden wir auch im lauf der
sendung noch kommen aber bleiben wir
erstmal bei den subventionen frau rapior
sind wir da schon sehr schnell sehr hart
gelandet da sitzen sie monatelang
harmonisch an dem tisch und überlegen
wie man gelder gut und sinnvoll
verteilen könnte und zack beschließt die
eu und damit auch frau klöckner quasi
zeitgleich agrarsubventionen die dann
doch an die fläche gebunden sind und
nutze 25 prozent an
gesamtgesellschaftliches wirtschaften in
der landwirtschaft was läuft da schief
also harmonisch war es zu diesem thema
nicht das war auch der grund warum
greenpeace aus der kommission aus
gestiegen ist weil eben die politik eine
zukunftskommission zusammensetzt
gruppiert und aber parallel die eigenen
dinge durchzieht und das war von anfang
an streitthema wir können aber nicht nur
bis 20 27 schauen
die subventionen sollen ja wir wollten
einfach in der kommission überlegen wie
es langfristig weitergehen soll noch da
bin ich froh dass einigkeit besteht dass
die flächen gebunden direktzahlungen
vollständig abgebaut werden müssen und
das ist ein riesenerfolg für die gesamte
gesellschaft also öffentliche mittel
sollen künftig für öffentliche
leistungen ausgegeben werden und dass es
ein ganz großer neuer schritt wenn sie
das aus sicht des bauern sich anhören
der messerschmitt man müsste sehr viel
geld in die hand nehmen zusätzlich um
diese wende die frau aber gerade
beschrieben hat auch hinzukriegen woher
soll das geld dann kommen ja das geld
das ist nun mal ganz klar das kann nicht
allein wir bauern aufbringen und ich
denke bei mir im betrieb zeigt ich das
auch ganz gut ich mache viel was mich
auch unterm strich geld kostet und das
was ich dann im
in form von von verstärkter
bodenfruchtbarkeit über die jahre erst
wieder zurückbekomme das ist eine
investition in unsere zukunft
investitionen in meine böden
das geld muss ganz klar aus öffentlicher
hand kommen wir alle brauchen
nahrungsmittel wir alle wollen essen
wir alle müssen ja wir sind quasi auf
angewiesen auf die landwirtschaft ich
als landwirt bin auch auf andere
landwirte angewiesen und da ist eben
wichtig dass wir gemeinsam dieses
problem angehen gemeinsamen dieses
problem finanzieren und das ist schon
ganz wichtig dass wir die subvention
sinnvoller einsetzen müssen
sie betreiben in fünfter generation
zusammen mit ihrem vater ackerbaubetrieb
in niedersachsen können sie noch mal
ganz kurz beschreiben was das für den
betrieb ist und was die
herausforderungen sind mit denen sie im
moment so umgehen müssen zuerst einmal
zu mir weil eine messerschmitt ich bin
22 jahre jung
wir haben eben einen nebenerwerbs
ackerbaubetrieb zu hause weil es sich
eben nicht mehr lohnt bei unserer
betriebsgröße wir machen jetzt rund 100
hektar ackerbau und eben rein macht marc
frucht bau betrieb und da sind meine
damen meine zukunft sehen wir haben
aktuell wetter extreme die ich irgendwo
abrufen muss ich muss die
bodenfruchtbarkeit halten wir haben
permanent den wegfall von
pflanzenschutzmitteln den ich versuche
durch eine bewusstere düngung mit oder
eine ausgewogenere pflanzenernährung zu
kompensieren
und was mir mittlerweile auch oder
aktuell auch ganz gut gelingt ich habe
aktuell eigene versuche im feld laufen
wo ich ein paar zellen habe wo ich
verstärkt mit der förderung der
pflanzlichen immunsystems arbeite und da
dann die chemische pflanzenschutzmittel
im prinzip nahezu weglasse oder eben
auch weglassen und da sieht man eben
ganz gut dass da auch ganz gute
ergebnisse erzielt werden können
darf ich das problem sind also herr
messerschmidt darf ich da ganz klar darf
ich das schon mal gerade einen haken
weil sie das thema pestizide
angesprochen haben das ist ja ein großer
streitpunkt
und ein großes thema auch in der
kommission gewesen da gibt es zum
beispiel ein kommentar von einem user
namens schalke 08 10 des pestizide
gehören nicht auf äcker und wiesen
allein schon wegen den ganzen anderen
kleintieren und bienen und so da sind
wir in dem spannungsfeld der user sagt
die pestizide gehören da nicht hin
es gibt bauern die sagen doch die müssen
dahin weil sie uns kann ich meinen
betrieb nicht führen und sie wiederum
gehen ja einen ganz eigenen weg können
sie sich in diesem spannungsfeld noch
mal ein bisschen orientierung geben uns
orientierung geben bitte ja wenn ja es
gibt immer diesen begriff pestizide
dieser begriff da wird wie eine sau
durchs dorf getrieben und das ist
einfach ein riesen problem
wir brauchen pflanzenschutzmittel und
der ohne die kommen wir auch nicht nicht
aus wenn wir wirklich diese steigende
bevölkerungszahlen ernähren wollen wir
können unsere landwirtschaft stark
ökologisieren beziehungsweise
nachhaltiger gestalten aber wir müssen
gucken dass wir gewisse probleme und
kräuter mit dem wir auch teilweise schon
probleme haben dass wir die im griff
bekommen dass wir teilweise krankheiten
pflanzenkrankheiten dass wir die ich
sage mal das war die pflanzen davor
schützen und dass wir damit eben die
qualität unserer lebensmittel unserer
ernte güter unserer erzeugnisse eben
auch hoch halten wenn zum beispiel pilze
jetzt im getreide fusarien pilze sind
das die sind uns menschen giftig wenn
wir nichts gegen diesen pilz tun dann
haben wir letztendlich sondermüll dann
das ist dann kein getreide mehr dass wir
zum brotbacken nutzen können und
ökologische landwirtschaft ist da nicht
die allein lösung wir brauchen sinnvoll
eingesetzt und intelligent dosiert und
ausgebracht ohne eben die umwelt zu
beeinträchtigen
brauchen wir hier mischen pflanzenschutz
das ist einfach
ja das ist so und hat den user
zurückzukommen
sie konnte sekunde geben sie frau rat
für die chance wie sehen sie das ja also
mit genau diesen
sind wir ja in die kommission gestartet
da stand auf der einen seite die
landwirte die gesagt haben wir brauchen
eine chemische pflanzenschutzmittel auf
der anderen seite standen wie natur und
umwelt schützen haben gesagt aber es
stimmt doch die umwelt die biodiversität
geht zurück und zehn monate haben wir
jetzt diskutiert und haben eben zu all
diesen kernfragen antworten geschafft zu
dieser frage zum beispiel sind wir uns
einig wir müssen pflanzenschutzmittel
chemische pflanzenschutzmittel
reduzieren aber ohne
pflanzenschutzmittel geht es auch nicht
weil wir die erträge auf den äckern jahr
brauchen
das heißt wir brauchen andere lösungen
zum beispiel mechanischen pflanzenschutz
also mit der hacke oder ähnliche dinge
oder auch den integrativen
pflanzenschutz also hier mir wirklich
versucht auch lösungen zu finden und das
ist uns auch gelungen wo sie das gerade
ansprechend mit den lösungen das waren
ja tiefe gräben habe ich anfangs der
sendung gesagt wie ist ihnen das denn
gelungen diese gräben zu überwinden wie
sind sie denn zueinander gekommen
also ich bin sehr positiv überrascht
anfangs war es nicht so einfach auch
persönlich war über jahrzehnte hinweg
man nicht oder auch nur schlecht
miteinander gesprochen hat es war aber
so dass es gab zwei jugendverbände ich
darf dürfte für die jugend umwelt seite
sprechen es gab die deutschen landjugend
die katrin muss und wir haben recht
schnell zu uns gefunden zueinander
gefunden und haben eine eine ziel ein
zukunftsbild vorgelegt das heißt wir als
jugend haben den schulterschluss einmal
vorgemacht und ein zukunftsbild durften
wie also vorlegen und somit hatte ich
das gefühl natürlich auch über andere
kontakte ist uns nach und nach schritt
für schritt sind wir zueinander passen
wir einander gewachsen und ja ich würde
sagen dass das kam so mit der zeit aber
natürlich sind auch nicht alle gremien
überwunden
aber ich würde sagen wir haben alle
mussten schritte aufeinander zu machen
und das ist uns gut gelungen
kann man denn sagen dass die konflikte
heute nicht mehr zwischen stand heute am
tag heute nicht mehr zwischen den bauern
und den umweltschützern bestehen sondern
eher zwischen den generationen zwischen
jungen bauern und umweltschützern die
sagen es geht um unsere zukunft und so
müssen wir uns aufstellen und ältere
generationen in beiden bereichen vor
allem in den bereichen die sagen sorry
aber diesen wandel könnt ihr mit uns
nicht machen will
er ist sie frau radio und dann sehr
messerschmidt ich würde sagen also zum
einen ja wir haben auch einen
generationenkonflikt ich habe gemerkt
dass junge landwirte landwirten viel
bereit ja auch zum dialog sind und auch
den klimaschutz umweltschutz als
selbstverständlich wahrnehmen im
gegensatz zu ja auch älteren landwirten
landwirten muss man natürlich auch
differenziert betrachten aber das ist
meine persönliche wahrnehmung aber da
ist noch viel mehr
die landwirtschaften die umwelt seite
hat sehr schnell in schulterschluss
geschafft auch weil wir uns einig waren
bei manchen fragestellungen dass der
handel zb der lebensmitteleinzelhandel
eine unheimliche marktmacht hat das
heißt bei manchen ökonomischen fragen
waren sich landwirtschaft umwelt sehr
schnell einig und dann hatte man andere
gegenspieler sozusagen die er aus
nachgelagerten nachgelagert in den
wertschöpfungsketten kam
lebensmittelverarbeiter aber auch
lebensmittel einzelhandel und zum
anderen waren wir uns schnell einig dass
viele umwelt und ökosystemleistungen
möglich sind wenn nur jemand zahlt
verbraucherin steuerzahlern oder auch
die bundesregierung da unterstützung zur
seite stellt das heißt vieles machbar da
könnten wir eigentlich geschaffen aber
auch nur wenn der staat da unterstützt
herr messerschmidt sind sie der frau
rapior näher als zum beispiel dem 60
jährigen landwirt aus einem
nachbarbetrieb teils teils also da
stelle ich mich auf keine seite aber es
ist so wir haben auch ein
generationenkonflikt viele dinge die ich
bei uns im betrieb ausprobieren
mein großvater ist 92 jahre alt da ist
auch immer noch jeden tag mit dabei und
und guckt und was machen die da gerade
viele sachen da sagt gott es will und
wenn das mal was wird wenn das mal was
das sind andere anderen generation die
haben ganz andere sachen erlebt die
haben andere zeiten erlebt und wir sind
jetzt in einer zeit dass des wandels in
einer zeit des umbruchs und wir müssen
da jetzt aufeinander zugehen es gibt
probleme mit mit älteren generation in
der landwirtschaft teilweise aber viele
sind da sehr mein vater zum beispiel
sehr aufgeschlossen den ganzen
nachhaltigen systemen gegenüber wenn ich
mit neuen ideen kommen wir dann setzen
wir die um dann probieren wir das aus
und versuchen
was möglich ist aber genauso gibt es in
große probleme mit
ich sage jetzt einfach mal
uneinsichtigen der unrichtigen
gegenseite wo einfach behauptet wird und
nicht irgendwo da wird gleich der dialog
gesucht es wird einfach nur gesagt dass
ich scheiße wir brauchen das nicht
pestizide vergiftet unsere umwelt so
einfach ist es eben nicht und das hat
das wurde eben auch gerade gesagt und
ökonomischen pflanzenschutz brauchen wir
auch pflanzenschutzmittel und das zum
beispiel kupfer als schwermetall ob das
jetzt so gesund ist das dann auch wieder
die frage aber von vielen das von franz
saison beigebracht werden
kupfer wird er von vielen biobetrieben
zum beispiel eingesetzt auch das nur zur
einordnung der hören wir mal gemeinsam
rein und und fühlen wir uns noch mal
rein in die stimmung 2009 10 als die
proteste so hochgekocht sind und 40.000
trecker vom brandenburger tor mit den
dazugehörigen bäuerinnen und bauern
obendrauf auf sich aufmerksam gemacht
haben
das finden wir sehr unfair dass wir
mittlerweile die prügelknaben der nation
geworden sind und deshalb sind wir hier
hier vorn antwort auf den politiker
haben denkt und sie sind ein paar
ordnungen man anderen wieder ein
bisschen zurück traum ja wir haben die
stimmen der bauern von damals noch gut
im ohr die haben sich gegängelt gefühlt
von düngemittel verordnungen von
auflagen zu mehr tierwohl messerschmidt
wie ist denn die stimmung heute hat sich
da aus sicht der bauern
was zum guten gewendet wir haben einen
stetigen wandel in der landwirtschaft es
geht immer weiter wir stehen nie still
es ist jedes jahr ist anders und ich
sage mal jetzt aktuell geht es auf die
an dazu die futterernte auf den
betrieben ist viel los da ist natürlich
geht dieses diese sache ein bisschen
zurück aber weiterhin haben wir
natürlich das problem dass wir teilweise
ja eine relativ verhärtete situation oft
auch hatten
aber man merkt auch in der
landwirtschaft dass der verbraucher
deutlich offener auf uns zugeht jetzt
nach der korona zeit
es gab noch nie so viele verbraucher die
in hofläden auf den bäuerlichen
betrieben eingekauft haben wir merken
also ich merke bei mir auf meinem
instagram blog zum beispiel aber auch
viele berufskollegen mit dem man im
dialog ist wir merken dass der
verbraucher stärker auch auf uns zugeht
und wir strecken die hand aus und sagen
guckt euch an was wir machen und wir
bieten ihm das vertrauen an
und das vertrauen das muss man sich
erarbeiten und wir würden uns freuen
wenn wir da noch stärker in den dialog
kommen regionalität noch stärker fördern
und unsere heimische landwirtschaft noch
stärker im vordergrund bringen so wie
ich jetzt auch schon mit dem tierwohl
label und in der in der
zukunftskommission landwirtschaft
daneben beschlossen wurde mit voller die
zum beispiel bis 2030 nur noch steil nur
noch fleisch aus guter steuer aus sehr
guter haltung zu beziehen
beziehungsweise anzubieten
dann blicken wir doch mal auf die
verbraucher weil sie beide die schon so
oft angesprochen haben
welche rolle die spielen da schreibt zum
beispiel ein user auch über youtube
namens geld ausgehen
die öffentlichen gelder werden von
landwirten doch gar nicht gewollt ich
nehme an dass nehmen sie sehen sie
anders ein messerschmitt aber lassen wir
den teil des kommentars mal so stehen
der der user streitig genauso wie er
okay moment dann dann mache ich den noch
fertig die gesellschaft die fordert muss
diesen wandel auch zahlen da sind wir
beim geld bitte schön herr messerschmidt
richtig und das ist eben das problem wir
haben wenn man in deutschland nicht mal
und guckt oder mal ins ausland fährt
dann wundert man sich wie günstig sind
unsere lebensmittel und die werden ein
stück weit künstlich günstig gehalten
das natürlich auch gut damit sich auch
sozial schwächere schichten eine gute
und sichere ernährung eben leisten
können das ist natürlich sehr wichtig
aber andersrum
dreht man uns eben die daumenschrauben
an und das ist das wo wir land würde
sagen wir werden die gänge bis zum
gehtnichtmehr und
im prinzip ist es ja ein
verlustausgleich dass wir im prinzip
diese direktzahlungen bekommen
in vielen fällen ich würde viel lieber
aus am am freien markt mithalten können
als deutschland für der eben sich für
umwelt und natur einsetzt und
gleichzeitig ökonomisch unvernünftig
wirtschaftlich produzieren kann
für unseren regionalen deutschen
heimischen markt und das sind eben
bedingungen oder eben auch wenn ich
blühmischungen anbau oder insekten oder
biodiversität verbundsysteme erschaffe
ackerrandstreifen oder oder bewiesen das
kostet uns alles viel geld und wir haben
dadurch im gewisse kapital ausfälle und
diese müssen wir kompensiert bekommen
und da sind wir dann wieder bei der
förderung dieser dinge denn viele leute
haben zum beispiel steingärten zu hause
ja da haben die insekten nicht von und
wenn wir diese ausgleichs die dafür
einen ausgleich schaffen müssen auf
unseren ackerflächen dann müssen wir das
auch honoriert bekommen und wir sind
gerne bereit dazu wir machen das aber
nur gemeinsam und alleine können wir es
nicht bezahlen j.mp schreibt über
youtube ja der bürger muss den bauern
wieder mehr unterstützen durch direkten
einkauf oder kauf in bäuerliche
erzeugergemeinschaften da sind ja auch
bei der regionalisierung und simon tewes
berger schreibt auch über youtube mehr
tierwohl finden alle super aber wenn das
kilo fleisch beim aldi einen cent mehr
kostet schreien dann am ende doch wieder
alle frau rapior wie sehen sie das und
das ist ja am ende auch eine soziale
frage also nicht nur ich sondern ich
kann jetzt auch sagen wenn er finde es
total klasse kennen sagen kann auf
diesen bericht endbericht der gesamten
zukunftskommission landwirtschaft
verweisen wir sehen es so dass die
verbraucherinnen verbraucher in
deutschland wieder mehr verantwortung
übernehmen müssen
wir stehen historisch auf einem tief und
zwar zahlen verbraucherin verbraucher
ungefähr 14 prozent ihres einkommens
geben sie für lebensmittel aus das ist
ziemlich wenig alte messerschmidt auch
gerade erwähnt verbraucher müssen
stärker darauf achten was sie ein
kaufen und was sie noch wichtig ist wenn
wir uns zum beispiel klimaschutz
angucken man kann fiel durch den eigenen
konsum tun
der fleischkonsum muss aus
klimaschutzgründen aber auch aus
gesundheitlich gesundheitlichen gründen
zurück gehen auch und das verstehe ich
auch es gibt den momentan ein label war
wie in der zukunftskommission
landwirtschaft sind uns einig wir
möchten eine verbindliche kennzeichnung
für das tierwohl für die regionalität
und für weitere faktoren auf der eu
ebene so dass es für verbraucher für die
verbraucherinnen auch einfacher ist zu
erkennen dass kommt aus der region und
hier wurde unter hohen
tierschutzstandards dass das tier
gehalten
also hier muss man die verbraucherinnen
verbraucher auch an der hand nehmen
bildungsmaßnahmen sind natürlich auch
wichtig und sie hatten es gerade erwähnt
eine gute sozialpolitik ist natürlich
auch wichtig gruppen mit geringen
einkommen brauchen eine kompensation das
kann man durch kostenlose kostenlose
mahlzeiten in gemeinschaftsverpflegung
öffentlichen einrichtungen aber auch
erreichen wenn und das ist nämlich auch
eine frage die in den in dem chat
auftaucht wenn man sich konkret anguckt
was denn jetzt getan werden soll
was schlagen sie denn vor also viele
maßnahmen stehen in dem in dem
kommissionsbericht drin aber wäre zum
beispiel eine idee jede abschlussklasse
einmal ins schlachthaus zu schicken
damit kinder vor augen haben wo
eigentlich das chicken nuggets oder weiß
ich nicht die bärchen wurst auf ihrem
teller her kommt wäre das eine idee oder
ist ihnen das zu radikal
nein also man weiß ja auch dass es einen
weg gibt also eine lücke zwischen dem
was eine verbrauchern brauchen weiß und
was sie am ende tut
am ende muss es ersichtlich sein was für
produkte man nachfragt also ich hab es
gerade schon angesprochen die
verbindliche kennzeichnung von
lebensmitteln ist total wichtig wie bei
den bio eiern ließ oder bei den eiern
dies geschehen ist auf eu ebene
das ist ein erster schritt aber es muss
natürlich auch so sein dass
klimafreundliche ernährung günstiger ist
wenn tofu teurer ist als es schnitzel
dann läuft etwas falsch weil es
unheimlich hohe umweltkosten gibt die
mit der produktion des schnitzels in
verbindung stehen aber nicht beim tofu
entstehen
das heißt da könnte man auch über eine
mehrwertsteuersenkung für
klimafreundliche produkte nachdenken und
das wird auch aufgabe der nächsten
bundesregierung sein
die maßnahmen die wiener
zukunftskommission landwirtschaft
vorgeschlagen haben die auch umzusetzen
und den koalitionsvertrag mit
aufzunehmen wobei man dann weil sie wie
tofu sagen natürlich auch wieder global
denken muss und gucken muss wie ist das
mit dem soja wie ist das international
aber das ist auch wiederum ein weites
feld
sobald er so ja also ja welches angebaut
wird wird er häufig für futtermittel
dann genutzt also dass soja aus
brasilien wird nicht essen nicht wir
sondern vor allem unsere tiere unsere ja
unsere nutztiere und von daher so
pauschal kann man das nicht sagen aber
natürlich sprechen wir über eine
regionalisierung wir wollen wir sollten
vor allem regionale produkte künftig
nachfragen herr messerschmidt ist das
was sie machen nämlich auf instagram die
leute mitnehmen aufs feld bei ihnen in
den betrieb ist das der richtige weg und
müsste da noch mehr passieren müssen
sich die betriebe mehr öffnen damit der
verbraucher auch die verbraucherin am
ende mehr geld bereit ist zu zahlen für
die produkte ja komm ich sofort drauf
eine sache möchte ich noch gerade rücken
es heißt so ja dass im prinzip oft
gewürzt gesagt dass in südamerika
angebaut wird das wird in unsere tiere
verfüttert im prinzip wird nur reststoff
daraus in unsere tiere gefüttert also es
wird einmal verarbeitet und dass das
dabei über bleibt das geht dann
überwiegend in unsere tiere also es wird
immer nicht als wird immer gesagt und
ihn also in gewisser maßen trifft das
dann auch zu aber es ist nicht rein eben
die tierernährung wodurch das kommt auf
ihre frage zurückzukommen
auf jeden fall das sollte mehr ins auge
gefasst werden gerade auch in der
ausbildung junger landwirt sollte darauf
eingegangen werden wie gehe ich auf dem
verbraucher zu wie ja wie erkläre ich
verständlich was wir da tagtäglich
machen und das ist
ich habe vor gut drei jahren mir dann
irgendwo gedacht das kann doch gar nicht
sagen wir werden total oft sagen wir mal
falsch verstanden oder da verbraucher
ein ganz anderes bild von der leyen
wirtschaft die wir betreiben und dann
habe ich mir eben den entschluss gefasst
ich mache diesen instagram kanal neben
dem verbraucher mit zeige ihm was ich
mache mache als soja alternative habe
ich zum beispiel die lupine bei mir auf
dem feld im anbau die ich eben auch
versuchen möchte regional zu vermarkten
und zwar nicht in die die ernährung
sondern ihnen die humanernährung weil
sie eben eine wahre protein bombe ist
die als königin des ackers wird es auch
gerne genannt
und ja so bieten wir dann wiederum
unsere lösungen eine eine von vielen die
wahrscheinlich auch bei ihnen intern
noch umstritten ist wenn man sich zb
oder nicht umstritten aber das ist ein
weg den ich alle gehen das muss man auch
sagen da sind sie noch eine ausnahme zum
beispiel gibt es die gruppe der freien
bauern das ist eine kleine verbands
vertretung es ist zwar klein aber auch
die stimmen gibt es die sagen zum
beispiel für 90 prozent der deutschen
landwirtschaft besteht überhaupt kein
umbau bedarf also das ist natürlich auch
das andere ende sozusagen sie die die
neue wege gehen und andere die sagen
moment mal das geht uns alles viel zu
schnell oder wir wollen einfach genau
das machen was wir schon immer so
gemacht haben am schluss der sendung
würde ich noch gerne jemanden mit in die
sendung einbeziehen die einen nicht ganz
um maßgebliche rolle in der ganzen
thematik spielten nämlich die
landwirtschaftsministerin julia klöckner
und nicht erschrecken sie hat heute ein
statement dazu abgegeben aber sie ist
eine sehr beschäftigte ministerin und
deshalb ist dieser ton auch unter sehr
bestimmten umständen entstanden schauen
sie selbst
dieser transformationsprozess den wir
angehen in die bundesregierung bereits
angestoßen hat wer geht nicht per
knopfdruck aber wir müssen konsequent
weitergehen und ich finde diesen aspekt
zum beispiel dass der staat die
öffentliche hand das finanziert was
diesem ziel dient da haben wir zb jetzt
mit unseren investitions und
forschungsprogramm genau diesen
schwerpunkt auch schon gelegt den wir
weiter ausbauen wollen dass wir nur noch
maschinen finanzieren wie zb 40 prozent
weniger pflanzenschutz und auch die nur
mittel zum beispiel ausbringen der
ministerin viel beschäftigt hatte leider
auch keine zeit in unsere sendung an l
zu kommen obwohl wir sie angefragt haben
vielleicht klappt es ein andermal
in dem was die ministerin da
angesprochen hat das ist der unter
anderem der standort bericht des
landwirtschaftsministeriums von 2009/10
und schon da und wir erinnern uns das
war die zeit der traktor proteste schon
da steht tierwohl fördern gewässer
bewahren in diesem standort bericht was
hat sich denn von damals zu heute
verändert und inwiefern ist dieser
kommissionsbericht der heute vorgelegt
wurde denn tatsächlich so revolutionär
wie er heute dargestellt wird oder wie
wir ihn jetzt wahrnehmen frau ratio also
zumal ist jetzt natürlich ist klar die
ministerin tut so als würde unsere
empfehlung ihren kurs bestätigen
das kann ich gut nachvollziehen
entspricht aber nicht der realität
also wir haben in dem endbericht
wirklich einen umbruch eine
ökologisierung für die landwirtschaft
vorgesehen sind viele neue maßnahmen da
und nur war in einem ihrer berichte
drinsteht dass man auch gewässer
schützen muss heißt das nicht dass unser
endbericht der konkrete maßnahmen
vorschlägt ihren politikers unterstützt
herr messerschmidt
ja ich dachte sie wollen vielleicht
direkt darauf eingehen sonst was ist was
kann ich auch gerne waren gerne sie wie
man was ich dann aktuell eben auch bei
uns auf den betrieben oder generell was
ich in der politik in den in den
dialogen ja zudem laufe der jahren
ergeben hat da kann ich einfach was
außer praxis sprechen
bei mir ist das wo alles laufend im
wandel
oft hört man eben neu oder bekommt neue
denk anreize neue innovation innovative
techniken innovative kulturen jetzt habe
ich gerade mit dem schier anbau begonnen
um eben die regionale
lebensmittelversorgung freie zu treiben
und aber auch in den
beratungsunternehmen und generell in der
landwirtschaft selbst ist ein umbruch zu
verspüren die leute fangen an
interessieren sich für für neue
anbaumethoden für mechanische
unkrautbekämpfung um eben chemische
pflanzenschutzmittel zu reduzieren um
diese um diese ziele zu erreichen
die von uns verlangt werden und die auch
wir selbst für richtig halten
und insofern der wille zum wandel ist da
die branche will was verändern
natürlich gibt es immer leute die
schneller sind und langsamer sind aber
alles an sich würde ich sagen dass wir
eine sehr positive stimmung in der
branche haben herr messerschmidt im
september wird gewählt gibt eine neue
bundesregierung auch die wird dann mit
diesem kommissionsbericht zu arbeiten
haben was erwarten sie von denen ja ich
würde mich sehr freuen wenn eben teile
umgesetzt werden gerade ist ja auch in
dem bericht zu lesen dass eben die
landwirtschaft das anreize geschaffen
werden sollen und anreize braucht die
landwirtschaft wir müssen am ende davon
leben was wir tun
wir können gerne in die in den anbau
pflanzlicher eiweißquellen investieren
bei uns dann muss die politik aber ein
stück weit auch anreize schaffen wenn
die märkte noch nicht finanziell
lukrativ sind wenn die märkte sich nicht
lohne ich kann keinen kult
anbauen die sich nicht finanziell
rentiert die nicht wirtschaftlich für
mich ist das würde mich ja dann wäre ich
irgendwann bankrott dann welche
irgendwann insolvent und das ist ja
nicht das ziel der sache da müssten
anreize geschaffen werden von der
politik und ich würde mir vor mich
freuen wie vor habe ja schon gesagt hat
diese gräben die wir so langsam
zugeschüttet haben wir sind aufeinander
zugegangen junge verbände wurden endlich
mit ins boot genommen vernünftig und
durften mit gestalten dass es extrem
wichtig und vor allen dingen auch dass
wir mit umweltverbänden dass wir land
würde das die politik dass der
lebensmitteleinzelhandel dass wir alle
an einen tisch kommen und das ist extrem
wichtig gewesen und das ist auch extrem
erfolgreich und ich glaube auch nur dass
wir so alle mitnehmen können und sich
keiner ausgegrenzt fühlt und alle
branchen nach vorne gehen wollen und
eben ein schritt in die zukunft machen
wollen ich würde mich natürlich freuen
wenn anreize geschaffen werden die es
eben ermöglicht vielen jung land würden
wie mir die weiterführung unserer
betriebe zu ermöglichen
frage ob was erwarten sie von der
nächsten bundesregierung
also ich durfte ja als umweltschützerin
in der zukunftskommission landwirtschaft
mitarbeiten und die ökologisierung geht
ja nicht nur für die landwirtschaft
müssen jetzt und zwar innerhalb dieses
jahrzehnt jeden wirtschaftlichen bereich
ökologisieren für meine generation kommt
da eine riesige aufgabe kommt auf uns zu
und für die nächste bundesregierung
stehen jetzt eben viele entscheidungen
an
es muss jetzt her wirtschaftlicher
bereich ökologisiert werden wir müssen
anfangen
innerhalb von weiteren grenzen zu
wirtschaften und wie landwirtschaft
heißt das konkret dass diese maßnahmen
zur ökologie zum umwelt naturschutz zum
tierschutz und so war dann sofort dass
sie umgesetzt werden und zwar so schnell
wie möglich wir haben im zeitraum von
zwei bis drei legislaturperioden
vorgegeben aber man muss schon in der
nächsten legislaturperiode unheimlich
viel anstoßen
ich weiß auch noch mal betonen die
jugendbeteiligung hat in dieser
kommission
sehr gut funktioniert das möchte ich
noch mal heraus heben weil es noch nicht
so viele kommission gab bei denen
jugendverband vertreterinnen dabei sein
durften und ich fand das super dass es
hier so gut funktioniert hat könnte ja
auch ein gutes vorbild sein für andere
politikfelder in denen die gräfin die
gräben genauso tief sind vielen dank
miriam rapior und vielen dank malte
messerschmidt fürs mitdiskutieren und
für ihre meinungen und positionen und
ihnen liebe userinnen und user auch
vielen dank fürs mitmachen fragen
stellen und kommentieren und damit bis
zum nächsten mal und einen schönen abend
noch